we're going to use a hacking device
Wi-Fi pineapple to test how easy it is
to hack through a public network Let's
Play a scene at an airport see our
victim automatically turns on Wi-Fi yeah
she wants to check out socials right now
she notices a network with the
attractive name free Wi-Fi the network
is open cool connected the browser pops
up with a nice familiar window it's just
end-to-end authentication what could go
wrong right at this point a red light on
the device lights up and all the entered
credentials are on that Hacker's device
this wi-fi pineapple attack is called
evil twin and it is just one of them
want to know more attacks and protection
tools watch the big video link in the
comments be careful